intro to geometry is the heading but
having made that heading
i actually want you to make this heading
and then i want you to
cross out the word geometry
okay now here's why okay i actually
think
calling this geometry is maybe a bit of
a mistake just geometry by itself
because you get the idea that a lot of
things you learn in maths are kind of
like this right in case you can't quite
see this is like ancient writing that's
been engraved in stone okay now
sometimes we approach a subject and it's
kind of like look
everything we know about this subject is
now set in stone and you just have the
job of learning what other people have
already decided and written down and
that's why it's in a textbook and so on
okay
the reality is
the reason why i don't want you to just
make the heading geometry
is because geometry is not set in stone
it never has been
people have been arguing about this for
centuries right and further developing
this idea in fact
as i get to the end of this you will see
that this is an ongoing project that's
still happening today
okay so in fact i think a better name
for this topic that we're doing it's a
little bit cheesy but
this topic really is a global historical
project it's the global historical
geometry project that's what this topic
really is it's it has a long past right
uh it has come from centuries as you'll
see in a second
and it's had contributors from all over
the world in fact i've put in a few
different countries there that will show
you the contributors to this project and
the project is still happening
it's still happening today it's pretty
exciting actually okay so what i'm going
to do
i thought about how to present this to
you in a nice clean way that will enable
you to sort of take some notes that make
some sense and be coherent
i'm going to introduce you to some
personalities some of them you know some
of you don't okay
um they are by no means the only people
involved in this story okay but they are
kind of like the main characters let me
introduce you to some people
here we go here's my first person right
and uh this is very very old so i'm not
expecting that anyone knows who this is
guys
i've heard some great suggestions
we are in the right country most of you
the person who this is is named euclid
that's the first little heading you can
make euclid okay
uh euclid lived a very very long time
ago and he was interested in shapes in
fact
he was the kind of person you can
actually see what he's doing if you
squint he's drawing shapes okay
he was the the main person who
introduced us this idea of understanding
shapes as these perfect ideas out there
like okay look right
um have a look at okay have a look at my
watch have a look at my watch
uh what shape just the face what shape
is the face of my watch
it's a circle right right
wrong it's not a circle okay not just
the fact that you know it's got knobs
coming out and all that kind of thing
but if you take like a microscope okay
and you zoom in on my face what you'll
actually find is it doesn't look like
this when you zoom in
it actually looks like
there's like green bits and dents and
all that kind of thing you zoom in right
and um this heats it like i've dropped
this a hundred times right it's nothing
like a circle it only looks like a
circle because you're very far away okay
but euclid said look this this shape and
all the other shapes that we see around
us they're kind of like
shadows of a real circle somewhere in
space that's like the perfect shape an
eternal shape in fact that's kind of his
reason why
he was interested in these shapes he
said look
these shapes
they they represent something about
reality they're deep internal right
they're timeless
23 centuries ago right he came up with
these ideas and we still use them today
in fact the geometry that we're talking
about like when we say geometry what we
really mean is and this is part of this
you can go under your heading for euclid
is called euclidean geometry he's such a
big character that this whole field is
named after him
it's the geometry of things on flat
surfaces you can see he's even drawing
them right a circle is a flat object
right euclidean geometry
is all about i should say shapes
shapes on flat
surfaces okay that's what euclidean
geometry means and in fact pretty much
all the way through high school
geometry means euclidean geometry that
was euclid okay uh he is in fact called
the father of geometry and that's why i
think
okay
but here's the thing right
and this is what i'm very excited to
show you right this is not where the
journey
ended okay not by a long shot let me
introduce you to the next person
uh i'm expecting no one knows who this
is right this person can anyone get what
country does he look like each other
i heard the right one
this man is named nikolai
lobichevsky
the name is a bit of a giveaway okay so
just let me come back to this right
russia 1792-1856
okay now we just looked at euclid right
300 bc
euclid's ideas were so big and so
massive
they lasted
right it's not because like no one
thought of new ideas it's because these
ideas were so timeless they just kept
sticking around and no one had any
different well no majorly different
ideas
until lobby champs and like i said there
were many people who he was working here
but he was the main person okay
what would you said well
euclid was interested in shapes on flat
surfaces right
but they're not all flat right i want
you to um picture something for example
um i want you to picture just a map okay
so here's a map right
and um you know it's got some some
country on it something like that okay
now i'm going to pose a riddle to you
which lovachevsky will help us answer
okay
here's the riddle
a man starts at a certain place the man
does three things first he walks one
kilometer
south
one kilometer
second
he walks one kilometer
east third and last he walks one
kilometer
north
okay now
in euclid's world this is what he's done
this is the path that he has traced out
okay
but there is a place and here's the
riddle i want you to answer for me if
you can right that is a place where in
fact
if you trace out those three steps
south
east
north
you end up where you started have a
think about it
there's a place in the world where if
you start somewhere you go one kilometer
south one comet east one kilometer north
you end where you started yeah
the north pole and i think nathan had
his hand right up well done you got it
if this spot here is the north pole
think about it right think about it
south is any group if you go south
actually from the north pole every
direction is south right you're walking
away from the north pole now when you
walk one kilometer east
right
what's happening you're um you're going
just around
like in a circle around the north pole
right when you walk back north
you're still one kilometer away from the
north pole so that one kilometer back
north
takes you back now here's the thing
right
this this reel doesn't make sense in
euclid's world
and the reason why is because euclid's
world is flat
but lobochevsky said hold on
why should we think the things are flat
the thing we're standing on is not flat
it's a well roughly speaking it's a
sphere it's it's not really a sphere is
it but that's the basic idea right so
loverchevsky explored this idea of what
happens
when geometry is not flat okay now
here's an example
here's an example of a shape that
lobchesky is called he called a saddle
because you know
you know on a horse you see what i said
but of course you might think that's not
a saddle
i know what that is
right now
this whole idea
of geometry that is not flat
it's groundbreaking it's so
groundbreaking in fact that uh it got a
new name uh just like euclidean geometry
geometry let me write that over so
longevity in geometry
is shapes
on curved surfaces
right
shapes on curved surfaces now i will
just quickly tell you and you might be
able to see why
the name lobochevsky in geometry
doesn't always stick not everyone's that
happy with the name can't think of why
so here's another name for it if you're
curious
this is not the only kind of shape right
there's loads of other ones like it's
just one example
a synonym for this another kind of name
for this which describes what the shape
is is it's called
hyperbolic
junction that's a fancy name this kind
of shape this curvature right
is a kind of hyperbolic shape that's
that's the name of that kind of curved
object okay so this is what lobchevsky
had as an idea right